what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
adding a video to the seven deadly sins
fact series if you haven't be sure to
check out my 10 facts about Eskin or
video which I'll link in the description
and at the end of this video today we're
going to be talking about Melly Otis the
captain of the seven deadly sins himself
if you want more some deadly sins FAQ
videos make sure to smash that like
month let me know and leave suggestions
for future characters you'd like me to
cover in the comments if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell for more seven deadly
sins videos we have a whole sub millions
playlist on this channel and we're
always releasing new $0.70 videos
including reviews of the latest chapters
now without further ado let's jump into
it Melly Otis if you really want to know
back number one if you didn't know most
manga and anime series started out with
a manga one shot one shots are defined
as single standalone stories and they
often serve the same purpose as a pilot
episode the idea is to get a sense of
people's interest in a new series the
simulations had their own one shot and
although you'll see a character
resembling Melly Otis and a character
resembling Elizabeth you'll be blown
away by some of the differences in the
one-shot story for starters Melly Otis's
and Elizabeth's personalities are
reversed
Melly Otis seems easily frightened at
times in the one shot and he is much
more shy around Elizabeth while
Elizabeth is less shy than in the
version we've come to know Elizabeth
walks around naked in front of Melly
Otis and Mellie Otis tells her not to
walk around naked and he says that he
doesn't want to help her take a bath
that is a complete 180 from the pervy
Melly Otis we know and love who is
always all over the much higher
Elizabeth some other differences include
that Mellie Otis can actually cook well
he has an absolutely gigantic sword from
the beginning and melioidosis tavern
looks more like Howl's Moving Castle
when it moves since Hawkes mom is not
present and either as Hawke those are a
few of the ways in which the seven
deadly sins manga and Melly Otis could
have been different if the mangaka NACA
Basu zukie stuck to his initial ideas
what do you think about these changes do
you like the idea of a Shire Mellie Otis
or do you prefer the pervy one we've
come to know so well back number two
let's talk about our protagonists
popularity if we look at the first one
people there were online votes and
postcards combined and Mellie Otis came
in fifth place while King Bongo thir and
get this Hendrickson came ahead of him
this to me seemed strange until I saw
that if we only look at the postcard
results Mellie Otis came in first place
followed by bond King and Deann this
makes a lot more sense to me so I'm
guessing people just took advantage of
the online voting system in order to
vote multiple times which explains how
King managed to get 120 1945 online
votes when he only got 226 postcard
votes in the second popularity poll
which happened in 2019 our boy Mellie
Otis came first and he was the
undisputed champion this time in a
series with epic characters like bond
and Eskin or coming in first place is no
small accomplishment especially when
you're asked pervy as Mineta from my
hero academia let me know who your
favorite seven deadly sins character is
in the comment section below
fact number three next let's look at
Melissa's Dragon Tattoo it is action or
a Boros which is an ancient symbol of a
serpent or dragon eating its own tail
the symbol signifies infinity and the
cycle of birth and death
obviously the symbol works perfectly for
the dragon scent of wrath belly OTUs he
is one of the strongest beings just like
the dragon is one of the strongest
mythical creatures furthermore because
of his father's powers Mele Otis was
cursed with infinite life every time he
dies he simply gets brought back to life
for all these reasons - Ouroboros was
definitely the perfect symbol for Mele
Otis vac number four as you should know
by now the seven deadly sins is loosely
based on Arthurian legend you got cam
lot king arthur and of course merlin
what you may not know is that there is
also a Mele Otis in Arthurian legend he
was the father of the famous knight of
the round table named Tristan
a contemporary of King Arthur according
to some accounts Melly Otis had Tristan
with his first wife Elizabeth Melly Otis
also became the king of Leonys so
perhaps that's a clue that Melly Otis
and Elizabeth we honest Vienna becoming
the king and queen of the kingdom of the
Onis by the end of the series we can't
expect the seven deadly sins to follow
Arthurian legend too closely because
knockabout definitely like switching
things up for instance Melly Otis wasn't
an extremely OPD man in the original
Legend and Merlin didn't look like
hot thirty year old woman but
nonetheless it's fun to compare the two
versions of Mellie Otis I definitely
prefer the anime one myself back number
five Mellie Otis used to be the leader
of the ten commandments and people
always ask me in the comments what
commandment and Mellie Otis possess well
here's the answer he possessed the
commandment of love the commandment that
renders people who hold hatred in the
presence of the user powerless the
affected person is unable to inflict
harm on anyone the commandment of love
is definitely the perfect commandment
formerly Otis to be associated with
because his love for Elizabeth ended up
shaping all of his decisions he was
willing to make an enemy of the entire
world for the one he loved there's more
I could say about this commandment but I
don't want to spoil anime only Watchers
too much in this video so you can check
out my other video every characters
commandment explained if you want more
information back number six
although he's a shortest sent only five
feet tall and arguably the youngest
looking Mellie Otis is actually the
oldest of the seven deadly sins three
thousand years ago
Mellie Otis was already mature enough to
be the leader of the ten commandments
although some other sins were around
3,000 years ago
Mellie Otis seems to predate that also
Mellie Otis can be said to be much older
for other reasons that I won't get into
here because it hasn't been revealed in
the anime yet but you can check out my
every sins true age explained video if
you want a full breakdown which includes
manga only information back number seven
for this fact let's look into some seven
deadly sins guide books to find out some
trivia information about Mellie Otis
most Emilio toises facts are focused
around Elizabeth to the point of
obsession his favorite animal is
Elizabeth and his favorite smell is
Elizabeth's body the thing he wants to
do most is cuddle with Elizabeth and not
surprisingly his weakness is Elizabeth
that's only a handful of way more
Elizabeth related facts his charm point
Ness is a Hogan the little strand of
hair that sticks up on his head a
feature that was not as prominent in the
one shot I love the fact that Japan even
has a word for this and if you start
looking around you'll notice that a lot
of characters have a na hoga including
Maggie saputo Kawa from Clannad one of
my favorite female characters in anime
interestingly enough Melly Otis doesn't
have a sleeping posture because he is
restrained by Hawke every night
which keeps him from putting the moves
on Elizabeth back number eight belly
Otis was born on July 25th making him a
Leo at times in these videos I like to
talk about how characters relate to
their zodiac sign when I notice an
interesting connection ironically Leo at
first glance seems more like the perfect
zodiac sign for Eskin or because it is
associated with a lion with pride and
arrogance and with the Sun however Leos
are also supposed to be natural-born
leaders which is definitely Mellie Otis
not only did he lead the seven deadly
sins he led the commandments before that
and if he becomes the next demon king or
king of leiana's he'll be leading many
more beings Leo's are also supposed to
be self-confident have a sense of humor
and like having fun with friends and
Mellie Otis checks off that list pretty
nicely back number nine next let's turn
to Mellie Otis's voice actors in the
original Japanese Mellie Otis is voiced
by the 33 year old Yuki Kaji we've
actually come across this award-winning
voice actor before in my shuttle to the
rocky facts video he is the first voice
actor in Japan to win the best voice
actor award two years in a row first for
voicing Issei from highschool DxD in
2013 and then for voicing eren yeager
from attack on Titan in 2014 in addition
to voicing malleolus Yuki also voices
Elle dressed in the seven deadly sins in
the English dub Mellie Otis is voiced by
the also 33 year-old Bryce Patton Brooke
along with voicing zelgius Bryce voiced
eren yeager as well he voiced many other
characters including Kirito from sword
art online not only can he fight
on-screen Bryce knows how to fight in
real life too he's trained martial arts
for 16 years and holds a fourth degree
black belt he's a three-time kickboxing
champion and has fought over 60 times I
gotta admit that's an epic and perfect
hobby for a guy who voices so many shown
in protagonists fact number 10 if you
watch my other FAQ videos you know that
in lieu of just one fact fact number ten
is usually a lightning round where I
mentioned as many facts as I can in a
relatively short period of time now
without further ado 3 2 1 list champ
melioidosis hobby is collecting ales
about truss has stated that Mellie Otis
rarely ever gets drunk and can easily
sober up if he does all those Elvis is a
better drinker than the average Joe we
are told that he's a lightweight
compared to Mellie Otis despite how
powerful he is
Mellie Otis only weighs 50 kilograms or
110 pounds according to the manga con
acaba Mellie Otis is the most handsome
character in the world of the seven
deadly sins his blood type is B he's
left-handed and although his cooking is
horrible his meat pie is considered to
be his best dish lastly Melly Otis
actually has two rooms in the boar Hat
one on the first floor and another one
upstairs with Elizabeth gotta love those
bar owner perks and that is it for
today's video I hope you enjoyed all
that talk about Mellie Otis who is
definitely one of my favorite characters
along with bond who do you want to see a
FAQ video for next you decide remember
that I already covered s Kannur and now
Mellie Otis if you're a seven deadly
sins fan I strongly recommend you check
out our very own seven deadly sins
inspired merch at anime AFRICOM we got
Mellie Otisfield Iraq s Kannur praise
the Sun along with many other designs
these are my favorite shirts to wear and
if you're watching this video I suspect
that you love them just as much I'll
leave a link to them in the description
anyways if you did like this video make
sure let me know by smashing that like
button if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is very important
bring that notification bells you
actually know when we drop new 7 that
Lisa's videos you can get even more
contents and crucial updates on our
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible especially want
to thank our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson and Kings eldress and are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans baby ray a 17 FF DP
Steven Ingrid ah a lowland autumn Maddie
Mac 239 and makoto-kun and the super
special patron whose greatness cannot
begin to be fathomed regan Harrison the
one who
get this has been acknowledged by Lord
we go himself if you enjoy our work and
it gives you value you can support more
of it by going over to patreon comm
anime OPFOR and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these some praising
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron Olli
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
anyways thanks again for all your
support praise the Sun and until next
time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you